[Music]
hi guys it's ria
as you may know i love challenges
especially
upgrading the ingredients with mother's
day coming up i want to take some break
and
today i'm going to challenge somebody
else and i have a special guest today
john hi i'm john from preppy kitchen
john is excellent at decorating cake so
i saw
it's fun challenge him to upgrade
store-bought cake
oh i am up for that challenge very
exciting and
the seaweed mother's day oh i have some
ideas for this
so i'm gonna get started right now all
right i will check
back in a bit i'll see you soon bye
bye i've got my mission for marie i have
these store-bought cakes
they actually smell good but they're
covered in a frosting that's made with
shortening and not butter
so one it's really difficult to decorate
with and two it just doesn't taste that
great step one
remove the frosting this actually peels
off
really nicely so cut in there it rolls
off that's pretty cool expose the cake
layer this will say
bye bye this is my first time taking a
store-bought cake from the store
and bringing it back to life as a new
creation i've used store-bought cake
layers before some of them are actually
really good
but i've never stripped one down and
started over again
look at that it's a beautiful color this
we're going to peel off as well so just
kind of cut into it and we're going to
remove that shortening frosting
if you really want to try your hand at
cake decorating but you don't want to
bake for some reason or you just don't
have the time
this is a really good solution you might
just pick up a cake on sale and say you
know what i'm going to try my hand at
decorating a cake and if it turns out
it's going to be delicious and
beautiful too then we open it up like a
beautiful victoria sandwich
this is like peeling an orange if you've
ever tried to get the orange peel all
off in one piece
it's kind of gratifying a little bit
fastidious one cake layer is free of the
frosting
it really does smell good okay set that
aside this last piece of frosting is
just going to get removed
with my offset spatula and with that we
can begin anew
my cake layers are all free i actually
have four layers in total because i got
two cakes
this is gonna get reused as well this is
a cake round people use these for
transporting cakes when you decorate
them
if you're doing this at home you can
decorate directly onto a cake stand and
it'll look really pretty but if you want
to transport it
get a cake ground or recycle one these
are plain vanilla cake layers they're
fine but i know really loves cooking
with booze so
i made a really simple but delicious
brown sugar
bourbon vanilla glaze if you don't want
to cook with booze you could use
maple syrup brown sugar vanilla any of
these wonderful flavors can be infused
into the cake and it's going to be
delicious
we're going to start building this up
with some swiss meringue buttercream i
made with
real butter and real vanilla and a drop
of bourbon in there too
if you haven't used this or this which
is a cake turntable
we're going to use a couple dots of
buttercream just to hold it in place
press that down and now the cake is in a
stick on its own because it's kind of
covered in a little bit of buttercream
still
center that on your cake stand and by
the way this glaze is completely cooled
you don't want to put hot glaze on a
cake it'll make it like kind of fall
apart and mush up
spoon that on and it looks and smells
amazing
it's going to soak into the cake so
don't add too much at once just slowly
spoon it over
and you don't need 100 coverage so don't
worry if there's some blank spots
now we're going to add the buttercream
you can smear it on i'm using a big
piping bag because i love the hypnotic
turntable action happening here it's
also really fast to build a cake when
you have a turntable
makes you look like a professional even
if you're not this process is going
gonna get repeated for the next
three layers whenever you're decorating
a cake i want you to know that you
can do it all you need are the right
tools some confidence and patience don't
get flustered try and have everything
ready
at your fingertips and then you're gonna
be smooth sailing baking
and cake decorating should be really fun
not stressful
i'm coating this cake in swiss marine
buttercream and as you can see it has a
beautiful
light blue color i'm gonna give you a
hint on coloring the buttercream in a
minute but for now
if you've ever made a meringue based
buttercream like swiss or italian
it's gonna turn into like this weird
seafoam stuff if you leave it alone for
a few minutes
so before you use it you always have to
give it a quick whip
just whip it up with a spatula and
you're gonna see it come back to life
and become
supple and silky these buttercreams are
amazing but they're not amazing if you
don't whip them
right before you use them this is gonna
go into a piping bag as well
and then i'm gonna cover the cake now
we're gonna use an offset spatula this
is like a knife that's
a little bit crooked it makes it really
easy for you to clean things up
don't worry if it doesn't look like it's
a mirror smooth finish you're covering
this in decorations anyways so it could
have some imperfections it does not have
to be perfect and this is really where
the cake turntable comes in handy
because it makes it so easy to get a
nice smooth layer
so right now you can see i have some
gaps in here that's fine i'm gonna use a
spatula
and just swoop up and down the cake to
fill those gaps in this
corner definitely looks raggedy though
this is where you use the offset spatula
again
just clean it off on your bowl and now
you're going to pull in while you turn
slowly and that'll just pull that kind
of crown of buttercream
in and give you a nice smooth edge it's
time to pop this into the fridge
you only want to chill it so it gets
nice and hard because
decorating on a soft cake is a nightmare
if it's hard you can wipe off mistakes
you can like kind of cut into it with
some confidence so just pop it into the
fridge until it is
chilled a little bit so it's hard to the
touch like 20 minutes or so
we'll be right back
now for the fun part we're going to
decorate this cake i'm using more swiss
meringue buttercream and i've already
made a bunch of pretty
colors but i want to tell you something
first if you just
mixed swiss meringue or italian meringue
buttercream with a food coloring
you need to microwave it it's really
weird but take a tablespoon of the
buttercream in a bowl
microwave it so it's just melty like
this it'll look like melted marshmallow
then we're gonna add the color to that
and that's our base
you can add the base to your buttercream
now and it'll mix in and give you
beautiful vibrant colors
today i'm using these gel food colorings
they come in a ton of different
colors and they're very concentrated so
you only need to drop and you can always
add more
hard to take away so go slow take a
scoop of your frosting and once again
this looks like a weird butter cloud it
does not look like a silky frosting
so you're gonna have to mix this in so
mix mix mix and you'll see it come to
life
okay we're ready to start decorating i'm
gonna get comfortable because
you want to have a really close eye on
the detail the tools i'll be using today
are a
variety of small palette knives
different petal tips and a skewer
the important thing right now is to have
fun this could be an abstract cake or
any pattern but because it's mother's
day and we give lots of bouquets and
beautiful flowers i think riya deserves
some buttercream flowers on her cake
i'm building up these flowers starting
from behind you're gonna pipe directly
onto the buttercream and then
pipe away to make this a
three-dimensional flower
it sounds complicated but it's actually
really easy and if you mess up
don't worry just add more buttercream so
i piped three petals
start with the very back and then you're
layering them so you can always add
a little bit of yellow or orange
buttercream for some pollen in the
center
and now we're just gonna pipe the petals
in the front it's a little bit
nerve-wracking but
it's actually so much more easier than
it looks
and the nice thing about the skewer is
you can use that to
nudge the petals around a little bit so
if they look like they're kind of droopy
you can use your skewer just to prop
them up a bit these could be floating on
the cake but i'm adding some green
buttercream for stems they're going to
be
anchored into a bed of flowing grass
that we'll add at the very end
when you use a petal tip by the way the
pointy end is the
edge of the petal and the fat rounded
edge is the base of your flower i'm
going to attempt to flour using
a curved petal tip it's a little bit
more challenging you want to put
more pressure on the base as you squeeze
because
more buttercream that comes out of the
bottom less comes out of the top
the buttercream will jump around don't
be afraid to just put it back there
it's a challenging tip but it makes a
beautiful flower
[Music]
so right now i'm going to use a piping
nail it's really difficult to pipe a
flower stationary but if you're twisting
it on a piping nail it's
so much easier get a piece of parchment
paper put on the top of your piping nail
with a dollop of buttercream and then
start by building a base
so twist a little spiral just like that
it looks kind of like a flower
bud and now we're gonna start adding
more petals as you pipe the flower
angle your petals out so the flowers
opened up and it'll look just like this
this is gonna be much easier to put onto
your flower
as soon as it's chilled so take this and
pop it into the fridge and then you can
just
place it on without disrupting the
petals and moving it around
i've done a lot of piping and painting
onto my cake we painted some beautiful
orange pink mauve and even yellow
flowers to paint the flowers you can use
piping tips or
palette knives anything will work and
you can even do a more
impressionistic style flower they look a
little bit smudgy
but it's like it's blowing in the wind
blurred by the sun they're still going
to be really beautiful
as you can see i actually notched into
the corner of my cake and placed
a move flower right there i love the way
it kind of
continues up and comes out it really
pops out at you
upgrading a store-bought cake is a great
way to save time you can focus on the
decorations
really just not rush on it and
still create a beautiful and delicious
dessert we built a lot of flowers on the
side of the cake we're going to add a
few for a pop
on top as well what you want to do
though is
build a mound of buttercream up you want
to have a little
conical shaped glob of buttercream on
your parchment paper
it sounds weird but this is what gives
you
beautiful height like an actual flower
if you don't make this your flowers are
going to be flat
and just not as beautiful as they could
be put that on your piping nail
start off with a little cone that you're
rolling around there so you're making a
spiral shape like the inside of your
flower and then you're going to
pipe petals coming out just make sure
you go
down as you pipe and as you get lower
start angling your petal tip
out a bit more so their flower is
opening up these can go
into the fridge to chill and they can
set up completely that way you can
handle them
or if you're brave you can put them on
right now so i have these comically
large
tweezers they're actually for placing
chocolates on pastries and
flowers on cakes but you could use a
pair of scissors as long as they're
clean
they come in really handy then you're
just gonna take your rose and place it
on top of the cake wherever you'd like i
think this will look nice right over
here
after you place your flowers you can of
course pipe just a few more petals to
fill things in it'll look
even that much more realistic and i am
still using my skewer
to adjust the petals as i have been all
day long so handy
i'm liking the way the cake looks right
now but we can finish the base
i'm going to add some little grass
leaves and to do this i'm going to use
two different shades of green a dark and
a light for some more
depth and just a little bit more added
realness and take that palette knife and
just start brushing it up
really nice and loose and you can kind
of come away from the cake and cut into
the cake have fun with it
right now i'm finishing this cake up by
piping some leaf-like grass with my
leaf tip just draw it straight up my
cake's all done
i'm a little bit nervous but mostly
excited to see what rory thinks let's
give her a call
hi john hi so how did it go
it was really fun making it i hope you
like it
tada so beautiful
oh thank you it's it carnations
there are a bunch of different roses
some tulips
an assortment of flowers for you ah
thank you
i wish i could try that i heard you like
to cook with alcohol
so i made a bourbon brown sugar
vanilla glaze for this so all the cake
layers are soaked in that
and then the swiss meringue buttercream
has vanilla and a touch of bourbon too
oh my god oh i wish i could
taste it it's so pretty yes i might mail
you some
thank you i know you work so hard and
having a little one at home is
not a piece of cake so here's a piece of
cake for you
thank you so much for this cake john oh
it's my pleasure
and i enjoyed my break without cooking
or baking
and i hope you guys enjoyed watching
john
made such a masterpiece cake i hope you
learned some tips and tricks so you can
make a cake for someone special in your
life
thank you so much for watching and thank
you bye john
bye real happy mother's day in advance
thank you
oh yes
[Music]
you